Okay. So, good morning. Uh, today we are
doing the gunpowdered revolution.
Specifically, we are going to ask the
question, how did Europe starting about
the year
1700 conquer the world? So, um, after
the fall of the Roman Empire, Europe
became divided,
uh, very poor and very weak compared
with the rest of the world. But then
starting in the year 1700, Europe very
quickly in only about 200 years time
will go on to conquer the entire world.
So today we are going to examine how
this happened.
Okay. Um so before we begin I want you
guys to remember a very important
concept that we have been developing
throughout this course and the concept
is this. The nature of the military
determines the nature of the political
system in societies in nations. Okay. So
the four specific examples we've looked
at are Sparta, Athens, Macedonia, and
Rome. Because Sparta had a hoplight
army, it became an oligarchy. Okay,
oligarchy means rule by the
few. the rule by the elite and hoplights
were farmers who could afford their own
armor and weaponry. Okay. Um, Athens had
a navy and so it was a democracy and the
idea here is that anyone and everyone
can row a boat and if you uh can row a
boat you can fight a war, you can help
Athens win and therefore you can
participate in the political process. So
Athens was a democracy. Macedonia where
Ector the Great is from
um it was a
calvaryarybased army and because only
the nobility could afford horses, it was
a
monarchy. And the last example is Rome.
Now the thing about Rome that made it
distinct from these societies is that um
it was willing to make tremendous
sacrifices on the battlefield because it
could replenish its soldiers with allies
from neighboring uh nations in the
Italian peninsula and as such it was a
republic. Now the difference between a
republic and democracy is that democracy
everyone has the right to vote. So the
decisions are based on majority v rule.
Okay. But in a republic it is ruled by
laws and tradition and history. So
people will do what has been
traditionally accepted as the norm. And
as such you can bring in immigrants into
into your society very quickly. This is
important for us because Rome will
become the model for America. Okay.
America is not democracy. It is
republic. a very important um
difference. So I got I want you guys to
remember this idea. The military the
nature of the military will determine
the nature of your political system in
your society.
Okay. All right. So um let's go over
some basic military history. Um in
Greece do when uh the polices were
fighting each other in very much the
same way that the waring states were
fighting each other in China uh the main
uh soldier is called the hoplight. The
hoplight means shield in
uh Greek. And um the thing about the
hoplight that's very important is that
it was a self-suffic self-sufficient
soldier, meaning that most of the time
the he was a farmer, but when there was
a war, he would grab his armor and his
shield and his spear and he would go to
war. You didn't need a
economy to allow the hoplight to exist.
Okay, this this was a self-sufficient
system.
Um over time the Macedonians will take
the hoplight formation and turn it into
the Macedonian phallax. Um and the
Romans will have their legion. Okay. Now
the difference between the Macedonians
and the Romans uh sorry the difference
between this um system and the
traditional Greek system is now you have
a standing army. These are professional
soldiers that must be supported by the
economy. Um, this is calvary, the Roman
calvary. And obviously these are
nobility because only they can afford to
have
horses. These are the Vikings that we've
studied before. Again, this is pretty
self-sufficient. The Vikings are able to
build their own ships very quickly and
repair them. and they are able to go off
in small bands.
Okay. Um the steps people became
archers, right? So the Mongol the
Mongolians are the classic example. And
again, the thing here is that
um these
people ever since they were born could
ride horses and shoot arrows and that's
why they were so effective soldiers and
that's why for the longest time the
steps people were the dominant military
force in the world. Okay, they could
come in and conquer all the agricultural
empires. Uh this will include the Yamaya
which we talked about but it also
include um the Turks and the the
Mongolians.
Okay. Um in medieval Europe they develop
a new system um where the knight becomes
the main military force in the army. Now
the knight uh as you can see it requires
armored horses and armored um and
weapons and this is very expensive and
so and you have to train from an early
age to become a knight and that's why
you now have a system called feudalism
where the entire economy revolves around
maintaining knights for war purposes.
Okay, this is where feudalism comes
from.
What makes feudalism stick um is the
idea of
castles. Um so feudalism is about
decentralization where the knights and
the lords have control over the local
territory and there's nothing the king
can do about it. Why? Because maybe if
there's a fight between the lords and
the king well and the king comes with
his army. Well the lords can just hide
in their castle. And as you can see, um,
it's very hard to besiege and destroy a
castle. First of all, there's a
defensive perimeter, the moat. Um, and
then the high walls, okay? And
eventually, um, the king will have to
give up. So, in the feudal system, the
king is more like a figurehead who is
appointed as maybe the
chairman or the elected leader. Okay?
But the king does not have that much
power over the local um
areas. This changes in 1453. Okay. In
the city of Constantinople. So for about
close to a thousand years,
Constantinopole was the wealthiest most
powerful city in Europe. They are the
heroes to the Roman Empire. They
consider themselves the Eastern Roman
Empire and they are invincible because
of their high walls. Remember we talked
about the Bison Empire before and for
about a thousand years Constantinople
was a was powerful because they were
invincible. You cannot you cannot
besiege the city. Okay. But in 1453 this
changes because the Ottoman Turks come
in with
cannons and they lelay siege to
Constantinopole and they destroy the
walls and this was
unimaginable before and so it's
gunpowder that allows the Ottomans to
destroy the once impenetrable Consenopol
and this marks a revolution now in
Europe. Now people understand that you
need gunpowder if you are to win wars in
the future. Okay, this is a revolution
now in Europe. So over the centuries
what will happen is this gunpowder will
radically remake the world in three
fundamental ways. The first way that's
important is the step people cease to be
a threat.
Okay. So for thousands of years the
steps right the Mongolians the Turks the
Naya they drove history because they
could come in and conquer empires and
establish new societies.
Now with gunpowdered the cities can
defend themselves against the step
people and eventually over time the
Russians will colonize the
steps and they will cease to be a factor
in development of global history. Okay.
So this is the end of the steps. That's
the first fundamental change. Second is
this will mark the beginning of Europe
as the dominant global power in the
world. It is China that invents
gunpowder right about over a thousand
years
ago. But it is Europe that will perfect
gunpowder as the ultimate military
weapon that and it will allow Europe to
defeat everyone including the Ottoman
Turks, including the Chinese um
everyone. Okay. The third and most
important fundamental change is that
gunpowdered will usher in a whole
society revolution that will remake the
fabric and structure of European
society. Okay. So I will explain all
three as we move on. But these are the
three fundamental impacts of gunpowder.
All right. Let's talk about um the the
steps. So before we discuss why the step
people, the Vikings, the borderland
people, they usually tend to win out
against empires even though empires have
much more resources, much more people,
much more technology. Okay, so this is
the uh chart that explains why the
Borderlands wins out in the end because
the Borderlands have energy. The people
are much more courageous. They're much
more hungry. They're much more
determined. Uh openness. Um the set pe
the border lens people tend to be much
more innovative. They're open to new
ideas. They don't invent things but they
take inventions and they apply it to
their society. The last is opportunistic
where um they will only attack you if
they think you're weak. Okay. Uh the
empire has three advantages. Mass
organization and death. Mass just means
a lot of people. Organization means a
centralized bureaucracy. And then death
just means that they can afford to lose
a lot of battles. Okay? And um for most
of human history, the borderlands had
advantages over the empire. But with the
advent of
gunpowder, the dynamic changes. So now
that the empire is able to control and
crush the borderlands, the main reason
why is with gunpowder technology, you
need organization. You need
centralization. Remember before armies
were
self-sufficient. You needed to go to
war. You told you told everyone, "Let's
go to war." And then the people who were
soldiers would get their armor and they
would rush to battle. Okay? That's what
the Greeks did against the Persians.
But with gunpowdered, you need a
professional army, you need engineers,
you need the resources that allow you to
make gunpowder. Okay? So, you need
specialization. With specialization, you
need centralization, hierarchy, and
bureaucracy. And that's what empires do
very well. And the borderlands don't do
this. Okay? And that's why eventually
the empires will win out against the
borderlands in the long term. All right?
Um so there are four major gunpowder
empires meaning these four societies are
most equipped
uh most ready to take advantage of the
gunpowder revolution. The first and most
important gunpower empire are the
Ottomans, right? They're the ones who
took the cannons, the artillery, and
they're the ones who destroy Conan Pole.
And the Ottomans after that became the
dominant power in Europe and the Middle
East. Okay, the Ottoman
Empire. Um, what made the Ottoman Empire
so fierce was the use of professional
soldiers called generies.
Geniseries are um young boys who became
sla who are Christian and they became
slaves to the Ottomans and they were
educated become professional soldiers
and because they're basically slaves
they owe their entire loyalty to the
Sultan the king of the Ottoman Empire.
Okay. And uh these are professional
soldiers who uh made effective very
effective use of gunpowder in
battle. Okay. So that's the Ottoman
Empire. But then you also have the Mogul
Empire which was the height of Indian
civilization. They were also for the
longest time a centralized bureaucracy
and they were also able to take
advantage of gunpowder.
Um then you have the Safetit Empire
which is in modern day Iran. They are
the heres to the Persian Empire. And
remember what you learned last semester
is it was really the Persians who
created bureaucracy
um in the world. Okay. And of course the
last uh and arguably the most powerful
of these gunpowder empires is China.
Okay. This is the Ming Empire. Uh
remember it was China who invented
gunpowder.
But what's interesting is when China
invented gunpowder, it was not used that
effectively. Um the Chinese army used
gunpowder mainly as bombs or as
fireworks, as inaries to blow things up.
Okay, it was but because of the Islamic
golden age and because of of
Genghaskhan's
conquest, globalization came into being
and the technology of paper and
gunpowder spread all the way to Europe.
It was the Europeans who in who
innovated gunpowder and turned it into a
propellant. Okay, something that that
you shoot people at a a projectile and
that's why we have cannons and
um musketss. And so it's the Europeans
who actually invented um gunpowder as a
projectile and then what would happen is
the technology would come back to China
and China would adapt this into their
own army. Okay. So that's that that that
that was a
process.
Um yeah. So this is China and uh the use
of
gunpowder. Okay. So the paradox is this.
It was China who invented the
gunpowder and the four great gunpowder
empires are the Ottomans, the Saffodits,
the Moguls and the Chinese. But at the
end of the day, it is Europe that
conquers the entire world. Okay, that's
the paradox. That's the uh mystery that
we're looking at today. And so the
thesis, the answer
is European nations would surpass the
gunpowder empires because they would
adopt a whole society approach to
warfare. Okay, so what does that mean?
It means that um if you are to have if
you are really to integrate gunpowder
into your military effectively, you need
to change the structure of your society.
You have to change the status quo. You
have to move from a society that is
heavily centralized to one that is both
centralized and open as well. Okay. So
I'm going to explain to you what changes
Europe had to make in order to uh move
to become a modern military. Okay. The
first change is it went from a feudal
system to a nation state system. Okay.
Does that make sense? Feudal is
decentralized local powers. Nation state
is you have a centralized bureaucracy.
Okay? You need that and that's what
Europe did. Second change is it went
from a focus on villages on agriculture
to a focus on towns and industry right
because um with gunpowdered you need
specialized workers you need engineers
you need iron workers and that happens
in towns and not in
villages. Okay, does that make sense?
Okay. Also, when you move to towns, you
start to create proto capitalism. So,
the merchants become much more important
than the bureaucrats because the
merchants who go and procur resources
necessary for gunpowder. The third major
change that happened in Europe that
really didn't happen anywhere else is a
shift in focus from
religion to
science. Okay. Religion is asking the
question, what does God want from us?
How can we best serve God? Science is
asking the question, um, how can we win
this war? How can we make gunpowder much
more effective? How can we kill more
people? Okay, so these are the three
major revolutions that happen in Europe
that really didn't happen anywhere else.
Okay, and when they happen in Europe,
um, it will unleash these extremely
violent and powerful revolutions as
well. Okay, including the French
Revolution, which we will study, the
American
Revolution. And it and it it's a bloody
process that takes centuries to unfold
and to develop. But it will make Europe
into the dominant power in the world. It
will allow Europe to conquer the entire
world and
force nations like China to adopt
European
um social frameworks. Okay, does that
make sense, guys? Okay, so that's um the
main idea
here. Okay. Um the main advantage that
Europe had over the rest of the world
was also its main disadvantage which
was Europe ever since the fall of the
Roman Empire was always divided and poor
and always fighting each other. Okay,
this this is what the concept we use for
for this in our class is open
cooperative competition. This is the
main driver of innovation in the world.
When was China most creative? During the
war and states period,
right? Okay. So, this is this is
consistently true throughout history.
Whenever a society is fractured and the
different constituent parts are forced
to fight each other, this will lead to
massive innovation not just in the
military but also in society, in
philosophy, in literature. Okay.
Um, so we talked about the three
revolutions in Europe that came about
because of the gunpower revolution.
Okay. All right. So, um, one thing to
keep in mind
is in the beginning it was not obvious
to people gunpowder was a
revolutionary force.
um it would take centuries before
societies the military used gunpowder as
the main weapon. Okay. And the reason
why is in the beginning gunpowder was
very unstable. It was hard to store. It
was hard to make and um the guns that
you use were too heavy. So they were
only a small part of your military.
Also, what's important for us remember
is that there's always been a battle
between artillery and
fortification. Okay, so even though the
Ottomans used the cannon to destroy
Consenipole, engineers would figure out
ways to better defend the city. Okay, so
the first strategy against um gunpowder
was the idea of earth works basically
and it's very simple. you just dig
trenches around your city and then
therefore the cannons cannot get get
come into range of your city. Okay, does
that make sense? So there are different
strategies you can use to
um negate the advantage of gunpowder.
Okay, so earth works is one advantage.
But then what they figured out was
something called a star fortress. Okay,
and this is a another revolution in the
military. A star fortress is designed
differently. Most fortresses before were
rectangular because they were the most
intuitive and the easiest to build. But
with a star fortress, you have different
points in the fortress so that you even
if one part gets destroyed, guess what?
You can fill the gaps, right? This part
gets gets destroyed, but then you fill
the gaps here, that part gets destroyed,
you fill the gaps here. Okay? So, you
basically have to attack the entire
forces at once. And most armies don't
have these resources to destroy the
entire fortress at once. You can only do
it part by part. Okay, you you want to
breach the for fortress, but the star
fortress allows you to be
resilient. Okay, to be flexible. The the
word that we use for this is ductile.
Okay, ductile just means the resilience
of materials.
Um the gunpowire revolution will also
mark um radical changes in military
formation, organization and hierarchy.
Okay. So um again at this particular
stage gunpowder is only a small fraction
of the entire army. Most people are
using spears and pikes to gather. Okay.
They also have cavalry as well. So the
problem for the Europeans is how do you
best utilize all these
resources in a much in a efficient and
effective manner. Okay. So this is one
possibility where the pikes are at the
back, the gunpowers are in the front and
the cavalry is to the wings. Okay. And
this provides most flexibility in your
army. And because Europeans always
fighting each other, they're always able
to figure out new strategies. Okay.
Um, this is a picture of an European
army in the 16th
century. Okay. All right. So, let's talk
about very quickly the formation of
gunpowder. How is gunpowder made? Well,
gunpowder is made using three different
uh resources. Okay, they are salt,
pepper, sulfur, and charcoal. Charcoal
is pretty easy to get. Okay. Sulfur you
get from basically from volcanoes. And
in Europe, the place where they had the
most volcanoes was Italy on the Ital
Italian peninsula. So if you look at the
history of Europe, most wars, the vast
majority of wars were actually fought
over the Italian peninsula. One because
you need sulfur for gunpowder, but also
because the Italian peninsula could
control trade with the rest of the
world. And also because the church was
there, the pope was there.
Okay.
Um, so pepper is uh the the the
technical name is potassium nitrate and
it comes from manure. Okay, manure. Um,
it doesn't really grow naturally. So
they have to farm it. They have to make
it. They make it basically by
um taking horse manure, animal manure
and planting in the ground and then
farming it. Okay. So this became an
industry onto itself. And so pepper is
important because um as they chemically
enhance gunpowder, they discovered that
um salt pepper should go from 41% to
almost 70%. Okay? Okay. So, salt pepper
was the main ingredient in gunpowder and
the Europeans had to figure out ways to
mass-produce salt pepper and that's why
they came up with these um uh nitiv okay
or
farms. Okay. And this became a very
important part of European society.
Um you also had chemists working in
laboratories to better
refine the technology of gunpowder.
Okay? Because because one huge issue of
gunpowder is it's very hard to store. So
for example, if it rains, guess what? No
more gunpowder. Okay? So they constantly
have to refine the chemical composition
of gunpowder to make it resilient uh
against rain, to make it easier to
store, to make it easier to transport.
There's also a good possibility that
along the way uh the gunpowder
u explodes on you. Okay, so this was an
absolute necessity to figure out how to
better make store and use
gunpowder. Um you also had iron works,
right? Because you need iron and metal
to make cannons which was the main use
of gunpowder. Um these are foundaries
where they will make gunpowders. And
again uh this helps us explain why towns
became much more important than
villages, right? Because it's towns
where you have the specialization going
on and not the
villages. Um the thing to remember about
the early guns called the uh arubus is
that they're very heavy. Remember these
are metal. Okay? So, uh, the soldier
basically needs something to stabilize
the gun. But even once a gun is
stabilized, it's not very
accurate, right? You can't it's I mean,
you're better off actually off with a
bow and arrow. And that's what most
people were using, bow bow and arrow.
Okay. The other thing about the Arbus
and the musket is it's very, very slow,
right? You have to aim it, then you have
to fire it, and then you have to reload
it. That could take uh
maybe 10 minutes, half an hour, you
know, it like the technology will get
better and better over time, but it's
very very slow. So, you have two issues
with the guns, the musket, the archabus.
One is that um it's not very accurate,
and second of all, it's very slow. So
the only solution is to have mass army
to have a lot of soldiers firing at
once. So you don't even care
uh you don't even want to aim. You you
just want to shoot it directly at
cavalry or or soldiers. Okay? And that's
the idea. And that's why um these armies
like the Ming and the armaments were
most able to use gunpower effectively
because they could organize mass armies.
Okay. So the Ming um were one of the
main innovators of gunpowder armies
using something called a folly. Okay. So
what would happen is soldiers were sent
in line that they they would come up,
shoot it, then walk to the back a new
line would come up and shoot it again.
Okay? They weren't aiming. They were
just shooting it. And this this is what
we call volley fire, right? So this is a
main tactic. Okay? So does it make sense
to you guys so far?
Um but over
time um gunpowder will be will become
much more effective, much more accurate,
much faster. Okay. And now what you can
do is conscript more
soldiers. So in other words, what is
required now is more conscripts for your
army. Okay. So this is a picture of
um a battle. But not only that, but you
need your soldiers to be obedient, okay?
Because you're asking them to charge
into
gunpowder, okay? And so you needed to
change the nature of people
into basically
peaceloving pretty
um simple individuals who were used to
freedom to ones who were obedient who
are bloodthirsty and who could kill
other people. Okay? And that's why you
have now have the invention of something
called schools. Okay? Okay, if you don't
know where skills come from, it comes
from the need to
um create as many soldiers as possible
for your mass army. Okay, so a concept
that I want to introduce you today and
we will go over a lot in um uh this
semester is the idea of synchronicity.
Okay, synchronicity is to structure
structure your society so that people in
your society are able to follow the
rules. Okay, they're able to follow the
rules, then your study can become much
more prosperous and become better uh um
can have more effective militaries.
Okay, so the two classic examples in
this world of synchronosity, the two
societies that do synchronosity the best
are Germany and Japan. Okay, go to
Germany, go to Japan and go on the
subway. Guess what, guys? Even though
it's really really crowded, everyone
stands in line perfectly.
Okay, everyone knows his or her position
in the lie and everyone's waiting
willing to wait in line. That's why um
in the 20th century Japan and Germany
had such effective militaries. Okay. And
also why they also have very effective
industries. Okay, schools will is is
preparing people not just for the
military but also for the assembly line,
the workplace.
And again, societies that are most able
to stand in line
orderly will be the most effective in
terms of industry and military and
that's usually the European societies
and Japan as well. Okay. So again,
gunpowder
uh marks a whole society revolution
changing not just the military and how
how wars are fought but changing the
very um nature of what it means to be
human. Okay. Doesn't make sense. If you
want to know where schools come from, it
comes from the need to fight wars. All
right? And again, um, China will adopt
all these
policies and struct social structures
for itself.
Okay. Um, let's go over some wars. So,
what's really important about Europe at
this time and and why Europe became the
dominant power in the world is it never
stops fighting each other. Okay, it's
always fighting wars internally and
externally against the Ottomans. Okay,
so um um the wars between Europe and the
Ottomans are called the Hungarian
Ottoman wars and this will last for
about 300 years. And in the beginning,
this really important is the Ottomans
destroy the
Europeans. The Ottomans are able to
destroy Consanopole and they're able to
take over most of Eastern Europe. Okay.
So, the Ottomans for many centuries up
until the year 1700 is a dominant
military power in Europe and around the
world at this
time. Um, there's also something called
the 100 years war that is fought between
France and England.
Okay.
Um, let's now go over some some wars.
And what I will do now is show you the
casualty count like how many people are
killed in action. All right. So again,
as I mentioned, a lot of wars are being
fought on the Italian peninsula. So um
the second Italian war, there's maybe
200,000 killed during this war. Okay,
these are soldiers killed, not
civilians. But when you get to a few few
years later, it's
31,000. Okay, and then it goes up to
30,000.
and then 75,000. Okay, these numbers are
going up. Why? Because the armies are
getting larger and the weapons are
getting much more precise and effective.
Okay, the this is the reason why uh more
people are
dying. The span English Spanish war it
is really important. Um 48,000 people
died. This is important because remember
last class we talked about about how
Spain is a dominant naval power in the
world and that's what allowed Spain to
colonize South America. But um in this
war England will destroy the Spanish
Armada the sp the Spanish navy and
England now will become the dominant
navy in Europe and around the world and
they will maintain this position until
America in World War II. Okay. So this
is a really pivotal point in history,
the sinking of the Spanish Amarda by the
in by the English. We said this 30 years
before um which was a religious war
between the Protestants, Protestant
Europe and the Catholics. This will kill
between 4.5 million to 8 million people
over a span of 30 years. This is the
worst war in Europe before World War I.
Okay. So these wars are becoming much
more violent, much more uh deadly.
Um, Spanish Portuguese war
80,000. Franco Spanish war 108,000.
Okay, you're seeing these numbers go up,
right? Franco Dutch War
342,000. Uh, war the Holy League almost
400,000. This is important because this
is when Europe is finally able to defeat
the Ottoman Empire. This marks a radical
turning point where Europe will now
become the dominant military power in
the world and the Ottomans will now
decline rapidly. Okay. Now you may be
asking yourself, wait a minute here, why
are all these wars being fought? And the
answer is
um Europe is divided among different
kingdoms and the main policy of all
these kingdoms is balance of power. So
whenever a new power arises the other
powers get together and try to take down
that empire. Okay? So before it was
Spain and then Spain was destroyed, then
it was France, then it was Russia, then
it was Germany.
Okay? So that's the idea here. Um 9
years war almost
700,000. The seven years war is really
the first world war because it's a war
fought between France and England for
control of the entire world. Okay? It's
being fought in North America and it's
being fought in Europe and almost a
million people get killed in this war
over seven years. French Revolutionary
Wars, we'll discuss this later on, but
663,000 killed. The French Revolution
wars is important historically
because a lot of people who fought in
this war, they are not professional
soldiers. They're just citizens who have
revolutionary devotion and fever. They
love their country. They want freedom
for the country. So they take up arms
and they're able to defeat much more
powerful European adversaries. Okay. So
this is this is the beginning of what we
call the nation state when the citizen
is completely loyal to the nation. All
right. We'll be talking about this um
later on the French Revolutionary Wars.
The and then of course the climax is
World War I and you get 20 million
people. Okay, 20 million people die in
this war. So you can see how the casual
rates just go up exponentially over the
decades. And that just shows you how
fast the Europeans are innovating. Okay?
They're innovating in terms of
bureaucracy, meaning that they are able
to tax their citizens much more
effectively. They're able to conscript
more soldiers effectively. They're also
innovating in terms of technology
because of science, right? They now have
like machine guns. in uh World War I.
They also have trenches. We'll be talk
about talk about this later on. All
right. So, as I said before, uh the
thing about Europe is that it's always
divided into different factions who are
always fighting against each other. And
what you will see what what these maps
will show you is two things. First is
that
um the status quo is always switching
back and forth between different
nations. Okay? So in the beginning in
1448 the Holy Roman Empire is a dominant
power in Europe with a population of 15
million people. Okay, that's the first
thing I want you guys to notice about
these maps. Um the dominant power is
always changing over time. The second
thing that you will notice is that even
though this is really interesting, even
though these wars are deadly, they're
continuous and they're becoming much
more violent. the population of every
nation in Europe goes up over time.
Okay, so
um 1554 the Ottomans now are in control
and they're at 24 million. The Holy
Roman Empire goes on at 19 million, but
France is arising. So is Russia.
Okay. 1623
uh the Holy R Roman Empire uh is still
around. So holy empire and Ottomans are
the dominant powers. But by the
time of 1666 1660 France actually
becomes the dominant power in Europe and
because France becomes a dominant power
in Europe all the nations decide to go
against France. Okay. And this leads to
a series of
wars.
Um 1727 France has has 23 million that
matches the population of the Ottomans.
Russia is rising now.
Okay. Right before the French Revolution
1780, France is now the most populous
country in Europe. Okay. 27 million. The
Ottomans have 26 million. Okay. And this
and this is right before the French
Revolution. 1824. The Russians are now
at 49 million. They become now the
dominant military power in Europe. And
this will bring them in conflict with
the rest of Europe. Okay, so England and
Russia will fight something called the
Great Game. We'll we'll be going over
this in in a future class. Okay, so the
rivalry between the United Kingdom and
Russia, which still goes on today, by
the way. Okay, it it's still going on
today, the Great
Game.
Um, Germany is now rising in 1890. Okay,
this is right before World War I. And so
Germany now is the dominant power in
Europe. So guess what happens? All the
nations in Europe combine together to
attack Germany. And this leads to
something called World War I.
Okay. All right. So that's the quick
introduction to
uh the history of the military
revolution in Europe. Okay. We'll be
going into specifics in future classes.
All right, any
questions about this? Was was this clear
to you guys? Okay, any questions?
How can they recover from?
Okay, great question. Okay. So the
question is um these wars are so deadly,
right? And so how's it possible for
these societies to be resilient and to
recover? Okay. Um so
um there are many different reasons
there different many factors going on.
Okay. But what's important is the rise
of something called the nation
state. Okay. So Indonesian state
replaces the role of religion in
people's
lives, right? Before you had to
sacrifice your life to the will of God.
You have to serve
God. Now with the French Revolution, you
now have to dedicate your life to the
nation. Okay? The glory of the nation.
What what And what does that mean? It
means like you have to do whatever it
takes in order for your nation to beat
other nations in war, which includes
um um working hard, making a lot of
money, but it also includes basically
having a lot of children. And this is
facilitated by the scientific and
agricultural revolution. Remember last
class we talked about how um because of
the age of exploration, the Europeans
were able to bring back the potato,
corn, tomatoes, squash. These are pretty
easy to grow and they provide a lot of
nutrition for the European nations.
Okay. But um what but what's important
is what's really driving the population
growth is war and the necessity for
having a large population. So the
government will provide a lot of
policies that promote population growth.
Okay, does that make sense? Well, we
we'll be discussing this in future
classes. All right. And I mean I I know
it's hard for us to
imagine, but war gives people meaning
and
purpose. Okay? Does that make sense?
It's it's like it it's like rooting for
a sports team. You want your sports team
to win no matter what. Okay? You're
you're you're going to go and cheer them
on. Okay? That's what war does. War
really
galvanizes the energy of people. So
people feel extremely patriotic during
wars. even though their children are
getting killed. The other thing that's
really important about war um is that it
gives people hope in the future. I I
know this is paradoxical, okay? But so
let me explain. With war, a lot of
people
die. With death comes opportunities that
didn't exist before that creates social
mobility. So it's perfectly possible
that you're a peasant but because of war
the nobility dies off and your son can
go join the army become like a captain
or a lieutenant come back and start his
own business and that wasn't available
before right because in peace time the
social hackery stays stagnant okay does
that make sense so um yeah I I mean like
and and so if you think about it it's
because we live in a world of peace
Okay, something called the PAX
Americana, the American peace. And
that's why a lot of young people refuse
to have children. Okay, why are young
people refusing to have children? They
really don't see a future, right? It's
like, I'm not going to rise up in the
social hierarchy. My kids aren't going
to rise up in the social social
hierarchy. There are fewer fewer
economic
opportunities. Your old people aren't
dying. Okay? They're not dying. I mean,
I know a lot of old people who are
extremely successful and they will live
over 100. They are like 90, 80 right now
and they are extremely healthy. They're
happy with their
lives. They're very wealthy. They don't
have they don't have any reason to die
and they won't die. So all that wealth
becomes monopolized by old people. And
so young people are like, why would I
want to have children? Why would I want
to work hard? Why why do I even want to
be ambitious? There's no point.
Okay. Does that make sense? Okay. All
right. Good. Great question. Any more
questions be before I
continue? All right. So, what I'm going
to do now is I'm going to summarize what
we learned. Okay. Um, just so you have a
clear clear understanding of how
everything fits together. All right. So,
feudalism. What is
feudalism? This is a system that was in
Europe for 100 years. Okay. in something
called the high middle ages or the late
middle ages which was maybe about a
thousand to 1400 okay 1500 okay so how
does feism workism works
because each part of society it's
partitioned into different lands run by
lords okay maybe lord A, Lord B, Lord C,
Lord D. The king was more of a
figurehead and he really didn't have
that much authority over the local
regions because each region has their
own army with castles. So it's very hard
to invade every single part. Okay? And
so um whenever there's a war, what would
happen is the king says, "Okay guys, we
need to go to war." So A would come in
with his army, B would come in with his
with his army, then C then D and they
would fight independently. Okay. And
what would often happen is that maybe C
betrays the king. Okay. This would
happen a lot in European history. This
is how most wars are fought
um in the feudal era. Okay. Now with
gunpowdered, okay, with
gunpowdered, okay, you need
centralization. Why? Because the thing
about gunpowder as I discussed is you
need a huge army in order to best
effectively use this gunpowder. So you
need two things,
taxation and
conscription. And therefore, you need a
bureaucracy.
Okay, does that make sense guys? You
need to do resolve these two issues. You
have to tax people to create a central
army and you need to constrict people to
fill the ranks of your army. You can
only do it through a centralized
bureaucracy.
Therefore, at this time, historians say
that the feudalism transitioned into an
absolute monarchy where the king now has
absolute power because a king only the
king can organize a centralized
bureaucracy. Okay. So now what would
happen is that um the
king would ask for conscripts from all
lands to create a
centralized
army.
Okay. So why you need to do this is the
nature of gunpowder.
So remember before um soldiers were
self-sufficient. If there's a battle,
they just went and got their armor and
then the sword and then they go off to
battle. Okay, with gunpowdered, you need
different elements. Okay, first of all,
you need
material. The the two main material,
sulfur and um salt,
pepper, and therefore you needed to do
trade and production.
Okay, you needed to create a gunpowder
economy if you are to have a gunpowder
army. But you also need
um specialists. Specialists are just
people who are able to make gunpowder
and who are able to use gunpowder in
battle. Okay, you need industry.
Industry are people who manufacture
gunpowder and manufacture cannons. You
need research. And these are just
scientists who help you refine gunpowder
over time. Okay. You also need a
bureaucracy to coordinate and you also
need a military hierarchy. Why?
Because these soldiers need to be
trained on how how to use the guns.
Okay? Okay, you need a hierarchy to
control the training of soldiers and the
deployment of soldiers in battle. Okay,
so so I mean like this is very simple um
what I'm doing but as you can see what
this means is you need a what we call a
whole society
approach.
Okay. You have to radically transform
your society so that it is all resources
are directed to the use of gunpowder in
battle. And the society that is most
able to do this will be the most
effective in war. Okay. And who are the
who are the people who are most able to
do this over time? The Prussians which
will become Germany and the Japanese.
Okay. And these these are just two
examples. also the Americans as well and
they are the most effective in in war a
whole society approach. Now the question
then is well okay the logic here makes
sense but why is it that it's Europe
that use a wholesale side approach and
not China not the Ottomans not the
Indians okay the reason why is
wholesided approach means a radical
transformation of your social hierarchy
and social order that's the reason why
all right so the Three major changes as
we discussed is to go from
feudalism, okay, basically an
aristocracy
to a bureaucracy. Okay, a national
bureaucracy bureaucrats. So the power
shifts from the
aristocrats to the
bureaucrats. Okay, that's one radical
social change. But then you have to go
from um
agriculture to industry.
Who? The
merchants. So now you have to give the
merchants, the capitalists, trades
people more power in your society,
right? And
and the bureaucrats don't want
that. Okay? And then you have to go from
religion to science. So now the people
with the most authority in your society
are no longer priests, which has
historically been true, but
scientists, right? So this is a
radical social transformation that
overturns the entire social hierarchy.
And that's why and that's why this is
really important. This is a process that
will take centuries and which will lead
to traumatic social revolution including
the French revolution, the American
revolutions. Okay, we'll be discussing
this later
on. Okay, so that's what you have to do
and most societies are not willing to do
this
because the elite don't want to give up
power. Okay, it's that simple. Okay, the
elite do not want to give up power.
Their power has to be taken away from
them. Okay. So, let me give you an
example to
illustrate how hard it is
to transform society. Okay. All right.
So, let's look at
China. Let's look at Europe. Hey
guys. So, China is um one of the first
societies to centralize. And when you
centralize, you
um accumulate a lot of resources. And
these resources allow you to make great
inventions. And so the four great
inventions of China are the
compass,
right?
Paper, print
making and um gunpowder. Okay, these are
the four great inventions of China.
China was the first to invent this by
hundreds of years. Okay. So the printing
press in China was maybe about the year
800. In Europe it would be 1400. Okay.
So this is like a huge advantage over
Europe. But these four inventions did
not really impact society in China. They
had no impact on society. But in Europe
when they are when they go over to
Europe the compass will bring
in the age of exploration, right? It
will allow Europe to conquer the entire
world. The age of exploration, right?
Paper and print making. What does it do?
It creates universal
literacy. Everyone in Europe is now able
to read and write because of paper and
printmaking. It radically transforms the
entire fabric of European society. And
because people are now able to read and
write, it gives rise to the renaissance.
suppressor re reformation revolution.
Okay. And the gunpowder allows Europe to
conquer the entire world conquest. Okay.
So think about that. Europe China was
the first to invent all four and Europe
was able to take all four and radically
transform the society and make Europe
into the dominant power in the entire
world. Right? So then the question then
is why is
it China didn't make
use of these four inventions? Just look
at paper and printmaking.
Okay. The problem in China is that you
have these confusion
bureaucrats and what is their source of
power? It's the monopoly over literacy
and knowledge production. Right? So they
didn't want to make it possible for
everyone to read and write because that
would reduce their power over the
people, right? Does that make sense?
Same thing with the compass. The compass
would allow Chinese to explore the world
and bring in new ideas and new goods.
The burgers didn't want that. They want
to protect the social
hierarchy. With gunpowder, yeah, it's
fine. But the problem
is if now everyone has a gun, they can
revolt against you,
right? Okay. So for China, it was much
more important to maintain a social
hierarchy than it is to innovate and to
dominate the world.
In fact, what's important for us to
remember is that if you give governments
a choice, they would always choose to
maintain a social hierarchy rather than
to to innovate because that's just the
easiest thing to do. But, and this is
important, Europe didn't have a choice
in the matter. It was a matter of life
and death. You either innovate or you
will get destroyed by your
neighbor. Okay, does that make
sense? Okay, great. Okay. So um so we we
did a broad overview of the history and
we'll go go into very specific details
um over the next few weeks. Okay. So
next class will be on the enlightenment
which will then give rise to the French
Revolution and the American Revolution.
Okay. All right. So but this is just a
very broad
overview. All right. So um questions
guys?
Yes.
Chinese.
Okay. So why did Europe innovate, right?
Okay. Great. So let's look at
Europe like let's just look at France or
Okay. Okay. So as a
nation you are under two types of
pressure.
external.
Okay, external just means
Britain,
Russia,
Germany, Holy Roman Empire. Okay, you
have a lot of enemies, okay? And so
you're competing against them. at the
same time that's really
important. You
have sorry
um
internal pressure as well. Okay? Because
remember what they're doing now is
they're recruiting more and more people
to join your army. And the general rule
is that if people fight for you, they
die for you, they also have a say in
your society.
Okay. Also, you need you need you need
you need to get people to have children
to replenish your population. You need
everyone to get get you need to get them
to work hard. Okay? So, you're always
afraid of
revolution,
discontent, and also the idea of
indifference, right? People don't care
anymore. So, you're under these two
pressures. So because of these two
pressures, it creates contradictions in
your society and these contradictions
force you to balance these
contradictions which leads to
innovation. Okay, does that logic here
make sense to you? Right? This creates
conflict and
contradiction, right? Which will then
lead to uh innovation. And if you don't
do if you don't innovate, then you'll
have a revolution or defeat. Okay? Does
that make sense? If you don't innovate,
your enemies will come and conquer you
or your people will rebel and overthrow
you. Okay, those are the two options.
You don't have a so you don't have a
choice in a matter but to innovate. But
sometimes the innovation can't keep up
with the social change. And that's what
happened in the French Revolution which
which we we will discuss uh later on is
that okay the government was trying to
make these changes but you have too many
social classes the merchant class uh the
educated middle class lawyers basically
you you have all these different social
groups now who want a greater say in
government but then you have this
hierarchy of like clergy, nobility
um and um bureaucrats who want to
maintain their privileges. Okay? And if
you can't resolve this conflict, then
the only outcome is
revolution, right? So, so it's either
you choose to resolve it or it will be
resolved for you.
Okay? So, this is a process of constant
innovation and revolution. Okay. Yeah.
Didn't China have the
Okay. All right. Um, that's a good
question. Okay. So, why isn't this
happening in China? Okay. All right. So,
um, the first thing about China, let's
say from Europe, is that China for the
longest time has been much more united
and there are natural boundaries that
protect China. Okay. So the sea, the
mountains, the desert to the north.
Okay. So China has these natural
boundaries that Europe doesn't have. Um
so from the perspective of Chinese
bureaucrats, they're not afraid of e
external enemies. Okay? Because like
Japan, Korea, they're not really threats
to China at this time. They're more
afraid of internal
revolution. Okay? So that's that's where
the focus is is on like how do we
maintain internal coherence? And the
best way to do that is by co-opting the
local elite, by bribing the local
elite. Okay? And the best way to bribe
the local elite is
by helping them stamp out local
discontent. Ensuring that the people
that are most loyal to you are always in
power in local
areas. Okay, does that make sense? So um
so the example is this. example is think
back to uh the Japanese invasion of
China. Okay, World War II. You look at
the KMT, the Guingong, which is a
dominant power in China. Japan is coming
in conquering most of China, controlling
the industrial heartland. And what is
Jangir doing? Does he care about the
Japanese? Not at all. He cares about the
Communist Party. These peasants in these
caves in north west China. Why? The
Japanese are a much more are a much
greater military threat, but they are
not a threat to the social hierarchy.
You can work with the Japanese, right?
The Japanese are perfectly willing to
work with you to control China. The
communists represent an overturning of
the social hierarchy. Therefore, they
are much greater threat.
Okay, does that make sense? But that's a
logic um in China. Okay, maintain a
social hierarchy. If foreigners want to
come and conquer China, that's fine
because we can work with them to
maintain a social hierarchy. Okay, but
uh these peasant rebels are the real
problem. Okay,
if their
best not
only value for social hierarchy but they
actually
not which emperor is exactly who it is.
Yeah. Okay. So that's a great question.
Okay. Um why is it that Chinese
dynasties don't last very long, right?
Okay.
So I I know this is hard to understand
uh but what what Chinese civilization is
it's it's a bureaucracy.
Okay,
bureaucracy because the bureaucracy
represents a social hierarchy. Okay,
confusionism. If the confusion culture
lives on, China lives on. So what's
important is to protect the confusion
culture which puts scholar officials
bureaucrats at the top of society. So
you can have the Mongols, you can have
the Japanese, you can have I don't know
Julian Jang. Who cares? The emperor
doesn't matter. You understand? The
emperor doesn't really matter in the
system. What matters is the
bureaucracy. And that has been
consistent for 2,000 years. Okay. Does
that make sense? Okay. So, so the
intention, the strategy is to maintain a
bureaucracy even though you may need to
put in a foreign
leader. Okay? In fact, you're better off
a foreign leader because a foreign
leader is much more dependent on the
bureaucracy than maybe a local leader.
So actually don't care about who is the
Yeah, it doesn't matter. The emperor is
just a figurehead. The emperor has has
no power, right? Because you think about
it, the emperor is just one person. But
the information that he gets is all from
bureaucrats. And therefore, you can
control and manipulate the emperor based
on the information you provide
him. Right? All right. So, it's a
bureaucracy that has all the power and
that's why China doesn't innovate
because a bureaucracy is too powerful.
Okay. Does does that make sense? Okay.
Great. Questions?
European countries like
Yeah. Okay. So that's a great question.
Okay, so the thing about the European
nations is that even though they're
divided, they um are basically one big
family. Okay, like so for example, the
Germans, the Russians, the English, they
were just like one big family. They were
cousins of each other, but they still
went to war and they still killed
millions of people. Okay. Um so how to
explain this? And the answer is um we
can use game theory.
Okay, game theory. Native game theory is
that you can be related to each other,
but you're all participants in a game in
which there going to be one winner,
right?
So um
um you still have to think about your
own survival and you can survive as long
as you have the if as long as you have
authority and legitimacy among your
people, right? Because if if they think
that you are representing a foreign
interest, your soldiers won't be loyal
to you. They'll they'll kill
you.
Okay? Does that make sense? Okay. And
also like like look look there's a very
common very simple
uh example where it's very common that a
king dies right and guess what what the
two sons start a civil war right they're
brothers but why are they fighting a
civil war and the reason why is okay
this really interesting is they
represent different political
factions who are all striving for hour
and the suns are just figureheads for
these political factions. Okay, does
that make
sense?
Okay. Okay. So, civil wars are fought
between different political factions and
they will appoint maybe son A to be the
head.
Okay. And son A if he doesn't agree
they'll find someone else. Okay. So
Evan's trying to be the top dog. Evans,
it's it's really okay. Yeah. So, so
there's a theory, but the theory is
called
status. What we really want is
status, right? And so,
um, brothers hate each other the most
because only one can have status. The
other
must obey. And that's why uh throughout
history so much violence has been
between princes, okay, who are striving
for this top top position. So so so
there are different theories. Okay,
great. Any more questions? You mentioned
that Europe schools
were institutions
that kind of
Okay. Um, so let's go over the history
of schooling. Okay. So the modern
schooling model that we use today is
from
Prussia. Okay.
Schools. Okay. And
so if you are a military, you need
soldiers. And what you discover is if
you want soldiers to be obedient, you
need to train them from an early age.
But not only that, but you need to
separate them from their families at an
early age. Okay? Does that make sense?
Because if they are separated from their
families, they feel more anxious, they
feel more stressed, they're less love.
Therefore, they're much willing to
accept authority and they're much more
willing to kill other people. Okay. So
that's a basic theory of schooling. Um
make them obedient from an early age and
separate them from the families from an
early age and then uh train them to be
soldiers from an early age. Okay, that
and this is a model that we adopt for
today universal schooling and every
country uses this system because not
only is it good for the military, it's
also good for industry, right?
Companies also want this system where
you go in and you work hard because
you're anxious. You want to make money.
You want to prove yourself, right?
Whereas if you feel loved by your
family, you don't care. You're like, you
know, like I don't like this boss. I'm
I'm going to go home and be with my
mother. Okay? So, um that's why every
nation adopted the system because it's
it's it was another for the military,
but it really helps with the industry.
Okay. So, the question then is why did
China adopt this? Well, because of
industry, right?
Because China needs factory workers and
the system gives you the best factory
workers. Okay, does that make sense?
Great. Any more
questions? Okay, so great questions,
guys. Um I really enjoy when when you
ask questions and and like they're
really perceptive. Okay, and I think
that by asking them you learn a lot as
well. So um next class we do the
enlightenment. Okay. And this will pave
the way for the American and the French
revolutions. Um, there's no class next
week because of midterms, but I'll see
you after after the midterms. Okay.
Okay.